alors ya une vidéo qui à propos de
céline dion vous allez voir comment la
star aurait traité une de ses fans qui
les faisait une démonstration de chat et
là c'est vrai que là moi ça m'a foutu
et là vous avez vu la vidéo à vos côtés
les spectateurs va nous dire ce qui est
choquant c'est après regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'il a qu'est ce qu'il ya moi
aussi je les adore chez hyper triste de
ce qu'elle a fait est ce que c'est par
les ménages
ol sur cette vidéo est un fait il s'agit
d'un montage on va tout de suite regardé
la vidéo originale le premier corps
[Musique]
alors là on en rigole mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ces millions a été très
affectée par tous les commentaires qui
l'ont cru céline tâche que je t'embrasse
c'est l'accent caire en plus ces
environnements et que je te dis que je
viendrais bien tu as mené d orignal au
canada coutras et que tu te mets dans
mon slip c'est est ce qu'il ya une star
qui vous a déjà déçu ou ah ouais vous
par exemple qui a way julie roberts jude
la robert berry quand j'étais à
célébrités on m'avait envoyé à new york
fin une interview de julia roberts
j'étais comme un fou ah ouais pour
vraiment il ya plus habiles et ne les
moyens bien en concorde etc et je suis
arrivé j'avais vingt minutes de prévu et
quand je suis arrivé là-bas pour
l'interview elle m'a dit je voudrais
cinq minutes non là j'ai pété un plomb
jamais franchement vous traitez les gens
ont commencé impossible et on s'est dit
ça julia roberts et engueuler les images
on s'engage été un scandale
ces témoins compte tout le monde à tous
les étrangers fait un petit bout chacun
est comme ça fait une interview condensé
jc c'est un scandale madame non je les
insulte et a insulté julia roberts ligne
offrent aux kings moi ce que je kiffe ce
que je kiffe dans l'histoire c'est que
tu as pris le concorde alors le concours
existe plus génial quand le seul moyen
de prendre le concorde aujourd'hui elle
est allée dans le cndd aux logiques
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais l'animal est pas déçu voix c'est
une rencontre loupé avec bruce willis
non extrêmement déçu bruce willis oui
pareil pour c'est sûr et bruce willis
était pas bruce qui pis est bonne à
paris à l'époque vous savez il est il
avait mis de l'argent dans le planet
hollywood
emma qui venait à paris à l'agréable cui
business - chanteur il avait affirmé il
venait et donc pour l'inauguration de
panique tony wood il venait faire un
mini concert et donc moi j'avais obtenu
pour tf1 les l'interview de bruce willis
ont et il était sur scène il qui fait
qui fait kiffer est donc qu il continue
à chanter et ils arrêtaient pas dire
pour la journaliste on attend qu'elles
attendent qu'elle attende quel âge de
vous la journaliste s'était moyenne
annuelle attendent qu'elles attendent
que tu achèterais c'était hyper emmerder
j'ai attendu j'ai attendu et 1h 2h 3h et
à la fin il s'est barré il est même
passé ni ses prix sinon c'est bien parce
qu'on a eus l'anecdote on temps réel ça
c'est rare c'est très rare d'avoir sa
canne et j'ai été un si on a loupé bruce
willis aussi exactement pour la même
raison c'est le même soir l'accord
ces exceptions et des milk et rooney qui
nous a demandé s'il avait senti quelque
chose c'était pas moi merci jean michel
non merci bob mckerrow qu'on s'en fout
plus personne aucun invité de la semaine
un invité pnp corrosif récit rico
reconcile freddy a oui évidemment et
après après l'émission en loges en tant
que professionnel on s'est un peu mon
traîneau et lui l'était il pleurait
et l'autre là casimir qui était contente
de dire que c'est et retourne sur l'île
aux enfants